new this morning our City's newest  professional sports team gear enough to  bring professional lacrosse to Las Vegas  Las Vegas desert dogs wrapped up their  first training camp weekend in Toronto  yesterday dog's first home game happens  to be inside of Michelob Ultra Arena  Friday December 16th tickets on sale  starting at 25 bucks but look at this  our goalies helmet Landon Kells  customized helmet it's got our City's  famous welcome to Fabulous Las Vegas  sign and it's got those dogs there on  the other side dangerous dogs you're  more impressed with the goalie gear the  pads they look like the Michelin Man  it puts the hockey goalies to shame I  mean my goodness so many pads all right